c'est la photographie de Orland une
artiste française très connue il s'agit
de profil de femme mon Bou et profil de
femme heureuse stéphanoise une
photographie qui date de 2002 et qui
appartient à une série une série
africaine euh Orland est une artiste qui
a toujours placé son corps au centre de
ses recherches artistique son corps
c'est son médium elle a souvent modifié
transformé en fonction des canons et
critères de beauté dans différentes
civilisations elle a commencé par la
chirurgie esthétique euh en transformant
son visage en lien avec des des icônes
de de la beauté féminine de la
Renaissance à travers l'histoire de
l'art
notamment Monalisa ou
bien la Vénus de btit Chelly ce sont des
des chirurgies esthétiques filmé en
direct qui ont été enregistré sur vidéo
mais aujourd'hui depuis depuis 1998
elle s'est adjoint les services la
technologie moderne la technologie
numérique pour poursuivre cette
recherche sur c'est une recherche
d'identité identité de la femme bien sûr
et donc le traitement de l'image le
morphine en
particulier là nous avons une un
métissage complètement improbable unee
femme
Mbou que l'on reconnaît par justement un
des critères de beauté de ce peuple
d'Afrique centrale qui est la
déformation du crâne et cette
coiffure de vanerie tressé et le profil
de l'uro stéphanoise ORL elle-même qui
qui est né à Saint-Étienne et que l'on
reconnaît là notamment par ces petites
bosses sur le les temp qui
sont qui figuraient déjà à l'époque de
ces chirurgies esthétiques hein des
petites des petits implants qui
modifient son visage et un autre
critère ce sont les bigouis hein qui
font partie de la panoplie de beauté des
femmes
occidentales le visage est éminemment
culturel
c'est ce que nous dit cette cette image
en fait hein et l'arthtech est bien sûr
très fier de posséder cette œuvre dans
ses collections qui permet aux abonnés
qui peuvent emprointer cette œuvre
d'avoir chez soi une œuvre de musée
puisque un autre exemplaire de ce de
cette photographie figure dans le musée
d'art contemporain du valde mararne à
vitrice sur
scène